und ist es bei ihnen also wenn ich ihnen
jetzt erst sehen was da geht es von
heute braucht man bedenkt dass sie das
nicht gemein zu wollen
das hat mir gefallen dass sie kommt da
schon zu bauen
[Musik]
die afg kommt zu wort carsten van ryssen
redet mit professor doktor jörg merten
vor den wahlen in baden-württemberg gibt
es eine fernsehdebatte im swr bei der
die als die nicht dabei sein wird da
wollen wir vom zdf ganz klar sagen da
machen wir nicht mit dass es nicht
unsere sache
deshalb kommen sie heute bei uns zu wort
wie genau lief das mit dem swr
der swr meine ich meine sie sind nicht
eingeladen worden
oder wieder ausgeladen worden also das
ist schon ein unterschied ist ja sonst
nicht eingeladen wir werden das kann ich
auch auf meine frau wird zum beispiel
sagen die ist auch sehr viel beliebter
als ich also keine ahnung warum
vermutlich weil die anderen sie einfach
nicht so gut kennen wegen mit welchen
parteien können sie sich perspektivisch
eine zusammenarbeit vorstellen also ein
bisschen abstrakt denken wieso ein
linksbündnis rot rot grün auf
bundesebene
also wir als politiker ein anderer lager
diese persönlich schätzen sie eigentlich
selber noch also auch für unsere frauen
putzen sie eigentlich selber im haushalt
noch machen sie damit im haushalt also
grund zu hause sitzen
sie sind es auch die spülmaschine
einräumen
ich nehme auch mal meinen wann bietet in
die hand und machen selbst wenn ich
ihnen jetzt selber ist mit an bord
also denkt sieht dass sie das gemeinste
worden mir gefallen sie kommt da schon
zu baut also nicht irgendwer meinen dass
es gehört die wahl der
selbstverständliche verschiedenen sind
denn auf der straße ergibt die beiden
relativ ungewöhnlich wenig sind können
wir dass der kurze moment still sein
ja ich bedanke mich damit gebe ich zu